oh it's starting oh it's bubble bags
thanks for the bits three all right so
it's blitz
but no increments so
playing a unicorn unicorn z
well i think i know this person do i
maybe i don't let's play a stafford
stafford time someone asked for it oh d4
is a good move
um i'll go into this line
and queen e2 is a move here and then
queen e7
yeah d4 is actually what i like to play
because it's the trickiest
so the idea is queen e2 queen e7 and
then
takes and d6
wait a minute is this okay bishop b5
bishop d7
this better be okay
oh there's some bishop g5 line
was gonna check this but then i forgot
hopefully it's okay
so there is one trap here if bishop f4
it takes takes
g5 never mind so opponent wants to play
knight d5
yeah i know gmd illusion played this
against me at some point
um i know it's okay
but i have to be very careful
oh happy birthday gangster
or gangster boy 9 000
i'll try just for you
okay so queen g6
takes takes
complete queen d6 for queen d8s
it looks really iffy but let's try this
taste takes
takes and probably king takes
this is really iffy
so the plan suggests fake castle rookie
king c8 got the king safe
maybe c6 at the right moment good luck
eric
that's a scary move oh thank you
it's okay like castles i play this move
because i need check i just take it with
my queen
like literally any night move forward i
take with queen
so this discovery isn't so useful yet
unlucky yesterday was a great game and
you did my favorite opening as white
it's my favorite opening too yeah i
tried
it was a fun match of you played well
oh thanks hansel slumming for two months
and thanks rusty yeah i'll probably put
the match on youtube
uh tomorrow probably okay this move
doesn't work
so probably f6
i've been watching around four hours of
your content
every day for a few weeks now oh wow
i've really been enjoying the youtube
uploading i'm in trouble
ones thanks i'm actually
am i in trouble maybe the snow
i'm in trouble um
okay i'm going to lose a queen
botox gambit
it's not so bad because i get rook and
minor piece i'm threatening this
and queen h is king c7 so
also b5 coming it's really not too bad
i have a nice time advantage
b5 not yet
just be safe
let's be extra safe
good move
um
okay not the cleanest game but it was a
game
it survived a very scary opening
opponent spent too much time trying to
refuse it
of all time probably searching for bobby
fischer
or brooklyn castle
has to be a chess movie though oh thanks
anton
and thanks for already something for for
half a year
and thanks earlier cole watching four
hours every day
yeah first time when bidding ooh
a wind bidding appreciate the wind
bidding
okay this this will be a long tournament
so
you just have to take it uh one game at
a time
i'll play i'll put e4 have some kind of
like old indian
so i prevent b5 and i want to play
bishop
c4 i don't mind the trade
um okay so i have the h file
not sure how valuable it is
and the big question is what to do here
maybe this move going for knight f5
a pressure sum some pressure points
thanks for subbing
cool oh that's a new sub
yeah if you're watching
four hours every day
i'll have to start uploading longer
videos
like knight f5
i play rook d1
the problem with knight f5 is like
eventually d5 or takes and then d5
so flat castles i have knight g6 and
nifty move
knight g6 rook h6 could be an idea
russia
friendly stream second day in a row
russia
usually i only catch up afterwards
hello to russia or privyet to russia
it's probably evening there okay can i
do this
let's do it probably gonna have two sets
of double pawns
but it's interesting
if i play g4 then it's uh it's some sort
of pawn chain
okay
oh this one's hanging
hmm
that's unfortunate
okay i'm gonna be down the pawn
and we're trading queens and i'm down on
time
and yeah black super solid too i'll play
g4
i might have to hope for another dirty
flag
it's still very it's still playable um
especially with obstacle bishops
it's not super difficult for black to to
crack my position
it's a slight surprise
i can't really punish that
i'll try this unleashing the rook
attempting to fix my my pawns too
hmm it's another surprise
so this pawn this pawn is probably more
of a weakness
and my epon's defended
haha there's a lot of content to get
through but more uploads is always
welcome
okay
yeah i posted every day for the last oh
from d3
okay i have to focus
i'm still alive i want to play this move
this is difficult though
because i don't know what to do in this
move rook f3
um
wow i feel stuck
oh my knight
okay i have to pray really hard here
okay i guess
i don't know what happened there um
thanks everyone for praying for me
oh opponent had a lot of time but the
king was
i guess very slippery okay so that's
that's two dirty flags to start the
tournament
i don't know how to feel
let's try and play solid i'll play this
line
okay still theory
yeah bishop g3 let's still go for this
maneuver
yeah this is a fun little night maneuver
uh question is what to do here
so opponent wants to play f3
i'll play queen e7 just preventing f3
trying to strengthen control over the
square
what might take and then play f3 or not
yeah just going for expansion i'd like
to kick away the knight
and then then just get the knight to e4
which i think i can do
i don't even take with bishop yeah we'll
stick with pogba
and youtube content your long aggressive
opening blitz arena videos am i
favorite i'll have to do more of those
debating which night to move
let's move this night
actually maybe so maybe this video can
be one of those
aggressive blitz arenas
so far it's a dirty flag arena
okay let's play bishop d7 safety first
this is a nifty move v3 queendix b3
knight t2
opponent wants to play this so this is
more of a just prophylactic move
if f3 i can take on g3 and then take on
e3
i'm trying mate
i'm going for the squeeze mainly going
for this
because knight's currently pinned to the
pawn
great content eric oh thanks so much
i'm trying
just play h4 so h4 knight e2
g5 oh yes i don't have time for that
yeah that didn't quite work
we still got in g5
so bishop wants to be here
everything's defended pretty much
eventually i'd like to play this
maybe right now
between c6 queen f5
trying to defend
this bishop is completely stuck
which i didn't fully realize
f3 might be possible though
let's go for this
so h3 is the main idea and then this and
then mate
just dropped a pawn
maybe it's not so bad look here and then
queen here
i just want to checkmate
yeah that's a move
play f5
the bishop is actually trapped that's
funny
so the king okay
it was a funny it's a funny ending
because the bishop just couldn't move
um
yeah i was actually expecting rook f1
takes takes takes
and the bishop still like it can't move
forever and then it should be just a
winning ending
okay that was a cleaner game i didn't
have to rely on dirty flagging
the other day i benched the 12-hour
tournament upload from a long time ago
and by the end
of the day i couldn't believe how much
yes i had watched
lmao i so i checked the stats of that
video
and only five percent of the people who
watched it
are less than five i think it was like
two to four percent
made it to the very end so
you're probably one of the the few
people that made it
congratulations
okay so we have one of these
oh it's supposed to be slightly better
here
but it should be playable
i'm sacking a pawn
there's some comp um if i can get the
bishop into play
white has some initiative knight d5
bishop g5
like once the bishop gets here though
there's a lot of things
to target
queen g4 h3
let's repeat once
i'm not going to repeat again
next emote should be a stafford gambit
mode oh
i could do that i have to unlock another
another emote slot
take that
this is almost 94.
my d4 is a cool move let's do it
it's attacked twice if knight takes on
me
i'm watching at a party with my friend
ryan martin
what is this
so i can take in queen c6
oh actually no this is just winning
should have taken no i never mind okay
this is winning
plenty of time okay that was nice
you're watching at a party oh shout out
to martin
and thank you my
collegial
man i can't read words today but thanks
for subbing at tier one
i'm just trying to think what the
stafford gambit emote would look like
because that's a lot of letters to fit
in one emote a strong player okay let's
play d4
i'll stick with london
and see the leaderboard here
so the idea is knight 94.
mm-hmm
i've studied this position with the pawn
and e6
i can still play e4 here
idea coin a4 considering
bishop e3 first
let's go for this
i lost a lot of time there
not the best opening
on the plus side i have the bishop hair
and black can't castle
still can't castle probably casting
queen side though
hmm
thanks for subbing biscuit fiend welcome
back becoming a twitch baby
and joda thanks for subbing i'd like to
play g3
but this diagonal scares me
if i take
maybe incorporate some knight g5
i do this
it's taking rookie one
it's kind of a sad move but i just want
to play g3 bishop h3
or knight d3 we can trade
yeah it looks better here opponents up
on time too
i'm still fighting controlling c4
controlling e4
these are like the two squares box minor
pieces want to access
i'll play b3
thanks for subbing because oh sarifas
gifting a son thanks sarifas
so these types of positions oh that's a
good 800 viewers
your channel is growing hello to people
um let me try and stay focused
i'm not comfortable here especially with
so many people watching
okay yeah the whites
worse his knights pinned the knight can
come to d4
i'm just going to be stuck
so the goal is to play quickly and the
goal is to just survive
like before good move
narcosis that's a norwegian for we're
having a good time
oh nice that's good to hear
defending
preventing rogue f2
[Music]
hmm
offer draw
yeah no draw unfortunately
there's a trick here it takes i can play
b5 and it's interesting
okay this is also really interesting
because i have so many pawns
what's going on here i might be winning
i'm up on time too
how did that happen c5 c6
is hard to stop
wow
wow final position should be winning
because whenever the king takes on b5 i
play c7
and meanwhile i just win on the king's
side
and the bishop's draft all right that
was
oh yeah i offered a draw yeah
yeah i mean the ending it was like one
of those endings where
uh it should be drawn
but i guess the fact that i offered the
draw maybe
provoked my opponent over push
okay have i lost a game
i've been losing games i don't think
i've lost a game yet
had that one draw
okay let's play play this move first and
then castle
so similar opening is previously
uh going to be very similar
at the same position oh
with knight f3
with another three ideas like this and
this
okay this should be roughly equal
expecting rook fc1 to work ac one
and the question is like how to improve
maybe 94.
94 is interesting
black can or white can't take twice
because bishop
c4 in the end i get an f5
i also have this move
i think i'll play this first
knight c4 i take on b5
oh what to do
actually not sure what to do here let's
find out six and then take
white's still probably better is this
the c file is going to be really
annoying
maybe i can take with queen hitting a2
and preparing
this
so queen c5 i can play knight d5
[Music]
hmm
this is very reminiscent of the previous
game where i was trying to attack on the
king side like this
this is a big threat wait this is a
that's a queen trap the queen doesn't
have any squares
it's h3a i take and the pawns pinned
meanwhile i'm controlling
i guess there's e5 in that line
or g6 queen e5 so maybe i'll play rook
88 first
it's not easy for the queen to escape
might see f4 that's a question should i
take
actually f4 there is
maybe i would just play f5 not sure
one's taking a long time here oh
actually f4 there's queen e2
a double attack
f3
i might have to take rook g6 is the
other option
[Music]
wait free pawn
rookie one knight f5
now e3 coming
g4 i can take the knight
it's getting weird i can take this
a lot of tension here
oh that's a fork that's a nice fork
can take that upon resigns nice okay
that's a nice game felt like another
clean game
titled arena yay good luck mr rosen
yay i barely know the rules you need to
get your title
you need to learn some more rules so you
can play in one of these
thanks for subbing for three months and
thank you
oh ali leah
starting a new sub at tier one thanks so
much
oh i'm playing a strong player play uh
another london
okay so top 50.
london time
ninety five
yeah so the idea with this line is after
it takes i play a4 and then
take the knight i'm pretty sure e6 is
actually a mistake black's supposed to
play rook c8
queen a4 here
oh i remember this line or do i
there's some crazy variation where i
like sack on b1
i thought i'm castled already though
also d4 is hanging it's not super simple
i've definitely studied a very similar
position
i'm just not remembering what to do
okay let's castle i'm leaving both pawns
hanging
if queen takes d4 i have queen a4
same thing with queen b2
the main point in this line is to
just eventually win this pawn
[Music]
another idea is night knight's coming to
a5
queen b5 probably a good move
it should still be pleasant
play f3 to start restricting the minors
some idea knight b7 to d6
it's my structure a long term
pawn monster on c5
i am down on time
control the file
let's go for this fiend cuddling the
night
it's probably close to equal
play this and go for a4 there's bishop
c2
e4 would be really nice if i can get it
in
um
[Music]
that's a good move
i can take here first
debating a4 here let's do it
not sure if this works but i hit both
things
rook's going to get active though
i just lose a pawn back too
and i'm down on time
i have one trap though there's a trap
here here
never mind let's go in
bishop h3 king f2
[Music]
okay
really oh tricky
oh no i'm allowing
ah
that didn't work how are you eric
uh could be better
uh oh that was such a nice looking
position
i was so focused on like what i wanted
to do i just
and so i saw
i saw rook takes c5 in this line i
should probably take here anyway
because takes takes oh no take some
defense
yeah i should have just moved somewhere
i should move here
no i move here there's still takes
maybe here it was a weird position
actually i should do this this this
ah okay that's life that's a cool game
though
had some chances um
still top 100 so that was my first loss
be a long tournament so carlson
oh ali pace is playing
he's doing well too all right let's play
play some chess kim another youtube
migrant
feels weird to be honest welcome time
travel
nice yeah because usually you watch in
the future but now you're watching in
the present
um okay we have the king's indian
so c4 c4 i think
i haven't played one of these in a while
i gotta wait for b3 and then play this
and fd7 is a typical move i'm not sure
if it's
correct here um ideas for
preserve knight c6
and then eventually getting e5
i'm not scared of takes
um
i like the square
i think i'll just go for like b6 bishop
b7
the pieces have pretty clear squares
maybe a f5 could be some idea
i'll play f5 don't see anything wrong
with it
maybe eventually i'll play e5
really oh i guess that doesn't quite
work yet
hmm
i wanted to play g5 but
timing's slightly off
it's still looking pleasant
just have to go for some squeeze
time for encouragement [ __ ] oh thanks
for that
i'm trying
hey let's connect four
okay so the main idea is g4
so take an a4 let's take first and then
take on d4 though okay let's do this
anyway
good position
okay queen c4
this move
so c5 should be weaker than e5
the king is just more useful too
tricky
you just want to win the pawn
this is very tricky no that was a mouse
slip
maybe not a bad mouse slip though
wow this is really annoying
ah
i'm losing a pawn too
yes let's go i didn't think it would
work
it worked though it worked haha
i really didn't think it would work wow
the classic eric rose and stalemate trap
usually it doesn't work if they have
like queen and rook and like no pawns
but i guess i'm pulling pre-moved rook
c3
wow
and i felt like i was in control the
whole game
until i just got low on time and lost my
pawns
wow okay back to tournaments stale bits
[Music]
still bits are some of the best bits
at least when it comes to stalemate
rose and trap bits i mean
so when the when the pawn was close to
queen
um i knew that was my only hope i didn't
think it would work because my king was
slow to get to the corner
but i guess it works did you start
calculating that
oh yeah i think i just answered that
but it was definitely a few moves prior
at least trying to get the idea
i think's double the pawns
yeah let's play this queen b1 line oh
what is this line oh we actually just
transposed
so bishop b7 e5
okay
yeah i haven't played one of these in a
while
double pawns gifting subs thanks so much
yeah this is some gambit line i don't
think bishop e7 is a move
i guess it is
your time is very relevant eight reasons
oh yeah could always use more
encouragement it's
thanks so much yeah let's go
appreciate that whoa even more
encouragement what is this
uh both rooks are hanging
scary
this is actually really scary
i have this move attacking defending
no idea what's going on here
draw oh no i work h7
opponent has d2 king g1
crazy position so ideas takes here mate
i'm threading made in one
check
check
[Music]
ah
ah oh man i thought i was being so
clever
king g7 yeah king g7 was a good move i
didn't see them made here
i'm sure there's something
i wanted to play queen h5 that the king
king escapes via f8
ah oh i should play queen h5 here
i think queen takes i'm not seeing the
mate
maybe queen h5 works oh the bishop's
just hanging oh
oh that was simple everything's running
for white man
after such a bad move oh it's still
winning though
i can still take the bishop man vision
was cloudy
all right um
well there's another loss
still fighting
okay let's play
let's stick with the main repertoire i
feel like i've been doing well with
black
okay playing this line oh thanks for the
bits
time for more bits
are those encouragement picks are there
just more bits
thanks cole let's take with pawn okay
let's um
we'll have we'll have a carlsbad
structure
the main idea here is knight f8 to g6
and then c6
and then eventually like this this this
it's still theory
those were just plain bits but these are
some more encouragement
oh thanks for clarifying thanks for the
encouragement bits
i do appreciate it
yeah so usually when the light comes
here this is a typical idea
just to trade off stuff and to maybe
trend this
i like the time situation
i want to take with her look just
keeping an eye on the square
and eventually knight g6
maybe there's some attacking potential
maybe not
i'll try this actually thinking about
this move
and here here with the thread of bishop
h3
i'm also threading this which i kind of
forgot about
because the knight's tied down to
defending each two
oh do i take the tea oh
the tea has been brewing for too long i
made a big pot
can i play this move let's move this
this
okay wait a minute i can also maybe take
let's go for this
so i'm throwing maiden two
yeah i can probably just take an h3
that's kind of sad threatening this cell
online f5
this is still a fight
at least the knights looked intimidating
[Music]
take on d4 let's take on d4
yeah white defended well um
actually i might be winning a pawn i was
thinking takes takes takes
takes takes but then i just takes an end
i went upon
[Music]
let me fix this t situation
whoa what does this move
oh that's a mate threat oh
oh that's a really good move wow
can i take this maybe i can
oh but there's rook
oh
i have to try i don't see any other
options
actually yeah rookie one just queen d6
and quindia that rookie it
meanwhile i won coupons
hello mr rosen oh hello brigham welcome
back
hope you're doing well
what what oh that's a move
okay let's trade
i'm still up a pawn
is going for this
unleash the the beast
may oh hey
okay that's a nice game i feel like i've
been having like clean games with the
the queen's gamble declined
rename it the cleans gambit declined
oh thanks love love subbing at tier 1
for
three months and cole thanks for the win
bits
appreciate that
all right let's play oh
i played this person in real life i
think
but where this name sounds really
familiar
what country is this boys
wonder if it was was it indonesia
it was indonesia because they played the
same thing worse joke ever bits
wait i studied this too there's bishop
d2 and then e4
yeah we played in indonesia
this was back in
january 2018 king's gambit
so i played this player i think right
after
i had like a six hour game there were
two games in one day
and i was feeling really sick and then
we played like a four hour game
but i still somehow won
and then the last round i was playing
for first place and got
like terribly destroyed
i'm pretty sure this is a player i have
to google it
hmm
that's a reasonable decision
play rook rookie one bishop f1 g3
queen g5 could be scary
final bits or the final bits
thanks cole for all the different types
of bits
stick with pawn i see three coming oh so
many bits
england gambit [ __ ] oh i don't know if
i'll play the england gambit
at least in this tournament
i want to play this with knight h3
the a5 very positional
okay three typical move
knight wants to be here
i'm not sure how to get there maybe
knight a4
to b6 to c4
i'll get tempo on the rook as well
okay so i have the bishop here now now
g3 is possible
always down for a staffer gambit
i played stafford in the first game and
almost got crushed
but it worked out okay going for rook b6
i like the position
also this pond's hanging
okay tactics time
oh there's f5
intake it takes f6
f6 bam hey
so pieces are coming off the board
while wind b7 can win e5 as well
also hey how's it going
butterfly bra welcome back subbing for
half a year
and not so great malenco subbing with
prime for four months
thanks for that
wait did i make a mistake
i can take i think it's okay
look here coming
it's a bit weird i might have six as
possible
wow i'm pulling someone nifty
my rook's trapped on g4
thankfully i'm still up two pawns
now three pawns
okay that was nice me uh let me google
this
i swear we played in indonesia
there's a small town called chila chop
yeah indonesia doesn't say
hmm
yeah fide's website is a little bit
weird
i lied apparently i bought more bits
than i thought
oh you lied so the the previous final
bits were not the final bits
well thanks for the unexpected more bits
oh around new 30 oh were there tactics
rook takes knight
oh i considered that i don't think it
quite worked
maybe it would have like liquidated
i know what you're referring to though
exci sparks
i think it would have just traded
wait what do i play here oh let's move
this is a good setup for white
because c5 is more difficult to play
with the rook on d1
so i play queen c8 to get off the d file
to prepare this
play win or a3 versus any french
i don't think i'm going to play an
opening i just have no idea how to play
at least in this tournament i'm more
willing to do
stuff like that and uh like some of the
days
or viewer challenge streams maybe
tomorrow
but yeah against good players i i really
have to stick with my
my own repertoire what i know
okay surviving this
always has really nice control over the
square i'm probably going to suffer
later
maybe i can take i'm taking bishop d5
idea queen c6 get the battery
f3 good move
and my clones are just fixed i'm trying
to make the best of this
i'm not sure if i want to play a5
because then it becomes a target
i'm actually really not sure what my
plan is
maybe this stuff then g3
so maybe this stuff
apparently white's not sure what their
plan is either so
and we'll see what happens
at situations like this you just have to
play quick moves
okay everything's defended
oh knight's coming to e4
eventually probably call pokemprod
if g3 then f3 is slightly more weak
i have no idea what my plan is what is
white doing
who puts the king on e3 what
play this move rook is unleashed
now i could maybe trade let's play rook
d4
i might even want a sack
i don't think it's even a sacrifice
because i have bishop f3 in the end
i'll be up a pawn it might be draj
bishop h1 is actually really interesting
should have one
um
okay we're gonna have some fun
oh that doesn't work at all for me
that was a bad decision
that was a really bad decision
so i think mates
it's still interesting
[Music]
there we go
all about the past pawn
let's go
intense bits okay
that was kind of intense
oh man
so maybe the exchange sack i guess
practically it wasn't so bad for me
definitely offered better winning
chances playing rain man
who is this oh armenia
oh another person who i played
in over-the-board chess so this is um
samwell
[Music]
maybe three is a move here i think
so i played him in brazil
at the u18 world championship
in 2011
it was the second to last round and he
beat me
and we were on board one and then he won
the tournament
so it was kind of sad
it was my first and only like world
youth championship
actually i got it i got an i am norm
that event
my first i am norm and i i needed to
play like all the gm's in my section
you know i played two gm's in my section
one i am
to even qualify for the norm
so in some way
this opponent contributed to my im title
i still want revenge for when he beat me
this is a pleasant position and
objectively it's probably
close to equal bishop d6
bishop g5
probably want to throw in queen of three
bits oh just bits
thanks for the bits
man that's so
you're just missing an adjective
the etiquette regarding chatting to your
opponent
is it a no no it's a no-no yeah
unless it's casual but like
over-the-board chess
you really shouldn't be talking
unless you're a grishak
there's some clip of the candidates like
krishuk is just talking to nepo like
during the game and then greece look
like immediately falls asleep
okay so i think my queen
maybe knight c5
so i have two bishops
that's a good move
oh there goes my pawn i still have the
bishop here so there's some comp
there's also this idea which is actually
maybe that's why he didn't take my pawn
so i'm holding on g4
rook a4 first actually let's play b4
actually i'm really indecisive
play this
bishop d3 i kind of hung up on
i just want to trap the queen
oh there's a funny line takes here here
rook takes
okay never mind
scary
before probably have to play rook b1
that queen is really annoying
okay finally lose a pawn but this pawn
is weak
and so is this fun
yeah the more pawns i lose the more open
files i gain
interesting
just gotta play quick now
duh
this is so difficult to play
no
[Music]
i tried uh
it was such a difficult position like
the night and the like
yeah the knight and the rook are just so
active and like my bishop and rook were
terrible
despite it being equal material
that was a good decision on his part
just to allow the end game
question bits question bits my rating on
liches is 400
higher than on chess tom do you think
this
is just because i'm more comfortable on
liches
this is a very common type of question
um there's so many different variables
but
yeah if you play more on one site then
that could have some effects
also i think i forget how their ratings
carry over
there's there's people that are more
knowledgeable than me
when it comes to answering this question
but yeah the ratings are going to be
slightly different regardless
what
i was probably a mouse slip
i propose i can't even propose a take
back
oh thanks for the bits akd 707 welcome
back
e5 was definitely a mass slip unless it
was like a dirty
attempt at like catching me in a
pre-move but probably not
okay so i'm up upon game continues
i just would like to complete
development
i'll play this actually yeah it's okay
c6 bishop a4 to b3
and queen a5 i have c3 defending the
bishop
so really i just want to trade off the
lightsword bishops
hmm
let's be safe oh
running out of bits [ __ ]
um
[Music]
running out of bits
wait okay let me focus i don't want to
let my guard down and then
like not win this position
it's still very comfortable and i've
found a happy place
pawn is under pressure and bishop here
maybe
v3 c4 at the right moment
probably have to castle first
can play f3
i'll play f3 and e4
so the bishop wants to come back and
then i want to queenside castle
and just enjoy the the center
it's really hard for black to do much
it's like the the pawns just restrict
everything
even e5 at the right moment could be
nice
e5 does allow for bishop f5
so i'll be patient
there's a lot of like just slow
improving moves i can play
i'm fine with the trade
everything's still under control maybe
knight c5
some queen h3
even queen f4
i think the queen pawn is hit
this is nice
insisting on the queen trade
opponent doesn't want it please
okay that was nice
man only 27 points the leader has 83
points that's insane
i guess yeah top players are berserking
a lot
probably makes sense if you want to win
the tournament
i just want to play i don't think i'll
bizer
i just want to play like decent chess
knight c3
go for this
some kind of like reverse london
i'm not sure my bishop is actually
useful here
so i think the idea oh never mind i
wanted to play c4
safe move
so we have some kind of like french
position
[Music]
opponent wants to attack me
actually this idea is kind of scary
i can't really like deal with it too
much
i can go for counter play
oh there's a cool idea here so it takes
takes and then this move
then 94 and then this and then this
can't be stopped
i'm just not sure about queen h3 93
knight g5
i'm kind of getting mated
let's play d4 first
because at night here then maybe
okay okay now i can take
and now this should be good yeah when
you're threatening a triple fork like
this
only one of the pieces can move and then
the other two pieces will get forked
that's a nice idea
um it's still gonna be a fight though
i spent a lot of time there knight's
coming here
this is a nice square for the rock
fork oh yeah i love fork knight bits
you gotta use the emotes
like queen c2 pawns are tender
um go after this pawn
i always play f6 all my time
oh the night the knights just almost
trapped it has d6
okay cutting off the king
i'm winning the pawn
okay i thought my opponent was going to
try and like dirty flag me that was nice
that's a nice little uh tactical
combination
so my original calculation was taking
first and then allowing that e4
um i didn't go for this because this
is wow
oh thanks so much cool even yeah
i just have to keep winning games for
the win bits
and thank you a federen for selling
with prime so
yeah white should play 94 here
94
and then i can't actually get the fork
because we could transpose i think i was
going to take here
and just enter this position
anyway let's move on
so i think the goal the goals top 100 oh
it's trust network
london time i've played many games
against chess network
chess network beat my oh i guess maybe
not a london
i'll play whatever this is
boring [ __ ]
oh so this is just like an old indian
a4 i know a4 is played at some point
thanks for the boring bits wait are you
calling me boring or
the the bits are just boring
there's nothing boring about playing the
og
chess network
idea i usually go for is this stuff
that's an idea
wants to play wants to play b5
probably just have to allow it
d5 is also a move here play d5
so if here i can take in bishop d5
encouragement bits must be chess network
oh
now i feel encouraged thanks for that
i bishop d5 anyway sub for 2
500 rating oh oh
i broke 2500 thanks for subbing i didn't
even realize that
i guess that was my one of my goals
of this tournament so queen b7
[Music]
i think this works
maybe it doesn't
definitely not calling you boring i
binged your 12-hour
oh that's right
what to do here though
rook going for the random rook lift
played way too slowly there
okay let's just trade everything it's
eric oh
that's me thanks for subbing dead man
no oh that man's just in the chat as
giallo thinks giallo
and nice ice starting with twitch crime
thanks so much all right let's focus
i don't know if the rook wants to be
there
but too late
so e4 g4
might as well bring the king in
that's a good move it's actually a
really good move
oh that's a really really good move
i can take
i'm not feeling comfortable here
yeah box pawns are scarier than my pawns
kind of
maybe i have g4 94
whoa it's money my two favorite players
i hope for a draw
oh i don't know if this will be peaceful
whoa my rook
it's a fork though
that was really bad i just wandered a
rook
uh any hope let's try this
i just want to win a pawn
b3
so i'm hoping for a draw two now
not feeling likely box pieces are a
little bit out of play
sadly i might be getting mated
don't make me please don't maybe
please
oh come back [ __ ] i'm trying
[Music]
well it was closer than it should have
been um
i'm not proud of rendering a rook like
that i should just play rook
i was so like focused on the square i
should just play like rook a3 v3
ah okay back to tournament good game
jerry
jerry's good very strong blitz player
well now i have a goal again i'm
breaking 2 500.
thanks thanks kingston
201 bits
okay so there's no hope in winning the
tournament
who
i'm trying okay i feel encouraged let's
play a staffer gambit
staff for gamba time
is the first like staff or gambit
accepted of the stream
oh thanks it's a
weird compliment but thanks
or maybe it's a nice compliment i didn't
mean to insult your compliments
uh queenie choose a move
i'll just play vision e6 and vision e3
bishop d4
so blocks down upon oh i probably have
to trade queens too
so how bad is this so the one form of
compensation is h2pawn
which i'd like to target
and i have to thank g1
okay it's a good sign
oh thank you
i'll take that i know that's a
compliment or a fact oh
and it's a reed it's anna kremling with
a giant raid
thanks anna kremling shout out to anna
kremling
i was so focused and
i forgot to turn on the the noise for
raids
i really appreciate that shout out
people should follow
anna kremling on twitch um great
streamer
has a lot of uh a lot of like
upbeats and very happy content
anyway i have to stay focused i'm still
down upon
white's defending everything
i play g5 wow oh
they're red bits oh so the previous bits
weren't the final bits i play c4 here
let's take and d4 is coming
so the rooks are both tied down c4 i
have this move
there might be some thread of bishop
knight g1
[Music]
let's try it
this king here i can probably play g4
i'm trying to take
okay so we're dancing around a little
bit
this is a funny move some
weird symmetry
bikini three here threatening made in
one
please miss it
he's gonna defend against it but it's
still a funny may threat
uh wait this just wins this windsor rook
wow that worked out
this is just a really kind of unexpected
mate threat in the center
i think white so white should play rook
e2
and then
[Music]
and black definitely has compensation i
could go after this pawn
and the knights pin yeah black's
probably better here
okay that was fun i was the first like
real
stafford gambit
okay hour and 16 minutes left
uh playing reward the encouragement
it's worked oh yeah i feel i feel even
more encouraged
after that game oh this opening again
so i'll just play reverse london
yeah let's go
go for this
leaps go nice face oh
thanks again
i'll play this move idea here and then
takes takes and i win the bishop
that worked out nicely that worked out
really nicely
opponent just gave me the bishop
uh
hold on still fighting though i could
try and win a pawn
just play bishop freeman
i love free bishops
the best things in life are free
especially bishops
the pawns look scary but i i don't think
i should feel
fear also i can maybe win upon
double attack
d4 is going to be very weak especially
after this
and this and this
i am allowing f6
hmm i have to be careful here
still trying to win stuff
this is looking a little bit risky
if i take
i think i can get away with taking
but maybe not
there's nothing much else to do
it takes takes takes takes
i'm not sure i'll start with this
oh oh
no
i might be losing this
let's try this
there's a cool trap
involve sacking queen look at this move
rookie rook d8 apollon can't mate me
because the queen is pinned
and if this i play this
i have 22 seconds
hmm i'm not three pawns though
i'm trying i'm trying and trying
funny position really funny position
oh let's go let's go
i was way more difficult than it should
have been
um i got way careless almost lost
opponent almost mated me and then
this was a really cool tactic
i just i i temporarily gave away the
queen
but it was like a double pin
and the main idea was if queen diggs b6
i take here with check
and then take back e5 with some nice
icing on the cake get her
karu and gotham chest to play in liches
oh
actually lovey used to stream only chess
i
like his his introduction to streaming
that was really nifty
thanks i feel even more encouraged now
and loxius gifting subs thanks so much
moxie is gifting to jokin joestar
george something something sir strife
sour krampus and mother care
thanks so much appreciate that
b6 is a fine move
wait what's the line here i know i've
looked at this
this is not a bad lining it's to london
if black plays accurately
it at least equalizes
but queen b1 is interesting because
there's some battery
i'm preventing knight e4 and
the reason for queen b1 and not queen c2
is
i preserve the c2 square for the bishop
in the event of c4
oh i crossed 2500 again i didn't even
realize
i think i played better when i'm not
like so wrapped up in reading first time
ever buying bits and i went kind of
aha i just really enjoy your content i
really appreciate it good luck in the
rest of the tournament eric
thanks so much yeah i really appreciate
the support
cole 1738
it's actually been like overall a
better than normal title arena i feel
like i've i'm in better form
maybe the fact that i played played this
match last night
was uh it was a good warm up
eventually i want to play g4 here
g4 bishop g3 get some attack rolling
opponent wants to play f6
hard to stop f6
i'm considering g5 here
but then it just takes
so i think my main plan is just to
prevent the eventual e5
going for an f3
e5 could still be coming maybe queen e3
and rook
e1 wow
does it work okay let's start with this
a very tense position
any fun opening recommendations for
black against d4
other than the budapest
uh i'll try and address that later
have to focus now
so if takes or is bishop e6 which i
think just wins
it's actually very close to force mate
because yeah knight g6 and queen this is
so beautiful
queen d3 and the king is completely
stuck i'm trying to double check
and the rook controls f8 which is
important
after it takes knight f18g a queen each
seven's mate
because rook would defend the knight
and there's like there's nothing for
black because attacking the queen
doesn't help
because of double check
so i'm pretty sure bishop e6 was force
mate
oh black has to take
and the attack continues that was nice
hi eric the first met you in london had
fun harry potter
rudolph and friends oh really
wait were you i'm trying to remember who
you are
i forgot about that night
yeah we went to like a karaoke bar
it was like midnight it was like right
before a rest day
during the world championship match
i remember like singing like
singing some duet with anna rudolph
that's a while ago though that was like
almost
almost two years ago
i'll have to dig up the pictures thanks
for the bits
ballpark frankly delicious
let's play let's play against the job of
london speaking of london
a3 is playable play a6 ideas to play c5
and not allow knights b5
i don't sing no i was probably so that
night was probably the last time i i
tried singing
the queen b6 here
i should have played bishop d6
probably have to review this
okay so bishop d6 doesn't work because
94.
this this looks okay i mean this is a
typical job
london structure where white's main idea
is e4
e4 might come right away
i'd probably just take trade bishop b7
also e4 can be met with d4
and then e5 oh white plays e5
speaking of london i watched the match
between you and navi
that was a great match dressing how you
clawed your way back
yeah also kudos to levy for choosing
different lines almost every game
yeah lovey has like a very flexible
rapper tour
he's capable of playing a lot of
different things
but yeah i i had to grow some claws
in the middle of the match in order to
claw my way back
queen g5 looks risky but
i don't see anything wrong with it i
just want to trade queens
queen yeah that was expected
in queen h5
it's not comfortable white's frightening
bishop
takes g6 or bishop e4
this is really not comfortable
wondering about e5 here
i'm gonna go for e5 because if it takes
i i counter attack
i think that's okay otherwise i want to
play queen
e6 ah that's a move
okay how bad is this
this is pretty bad this structure
reminds me of the french
i like the french there's some bits for
that
well thanks it doesn't change the fact
i'm getting crushed
maybe that's why it reminds you of the
french
thanks for the bits okay so i'm down the
exchange
um i have two bishops i have a pawn on
c3 randomly
the threat is this so i'm going to lose
a pawn
but maybe i can can expand
oh that's a good move i have to take
it's not plunger
ah
the queen g3
not seeing too much hope
this is my one trick
ah i'm winning in the final position
but i had no time bishop c4 is winning
actually bishop c4 is like very close to
mating too
like here here it would just say two
more moves
ah it's so close i mean
might deserve to win that but i was
happy to get some counter play
all right um playing dozer
so one hour left
playing f3 oh this line
pc3
there's some oh never mind
i thought there was going to be a funny
idea
maybe there's some idea like bishop c4
i'm gonna play this very greedily
is that a word
not sure
but the idea so they do just to defend
this pawn i have knight b6 i take and
queen b3
and greedily should be good
and bishop b7 coming
alexa defined greedily
greedily is an adverb usually defined as
in a greedy manner
with keen or ardent desire hmm that's
how i feel about
holding on to my pawns
ardent desire alexa define ardent
the adjective ardent is usually defined
as having
expressive of or characterized by
intense feeling
passionate fervent for more ask me to
give you more definitions for ardent
look at the center the center is so nice
if tanks i win the queen
if queen's yet i'd probably have to move
back
maybe rook team one
there's a lot of pressure here actually
maybe
let's try this take some knight g4
okay a lot of things staring at the pawn
rook d8 most likely coming and then
maybe i can put the rook on c5
and defend the pawn even more okay let's
castle
if here i play this in target f6
oh there's d62 should have considered
that
interesting i have to defend the
other d-pawn i have so many d-pawns
paul wants to chase my bishop
i think just h3 prophylaxis
and eventually rook c5
wait i thought i could win this
okay so we trade
hmm
um
maybe it takes takes
let's try this just have to simplify
bishops are really out of play
tricky move idea was rookie 2.
going after the pawn
um i think this works
because g4 in the end
and we're trading a lot
sack all the pawns
my time oh my pawn
okay got the draw
probably should have flagged at some
point but got the draw
oh man
okay that was an interesting game
very topsy-turvy probably spent too much
time
at some point it was working stafford
gambit no
vienna four nights copycat variation
really
i guess i can just trade everything this
is oh
it's expecting queen trade okay this is
pretty close to equal
oh why did i miss that
that's not good this is really not good
it was a knight h yeah
actually maybe it's okay
it's weird
because the knight is kind of pinned
there's 97 but then i take it
okay so i'm i'm down the pawn could be
worse
after this pawn
is becoming imbalanced
[Music]
oh
it's really unfortunate
ah that was rough
that was rough i tried to get counter
play it almost worked i guess d5 was a
good move
because it destabilized my whole b-file
blockade
of the rook
maybe i should have no a3 the bishop
controls a1
yeah mistakes were made earlier in that
game
okay life goes on
yeah so for this tournament i'm really
only berserking
if the player berserks first
it's alireza
seems like ollie razza joined late
hasn't played as many games
okay let's play let's play chess
i haven't had one of these today
yeah so when black plays in early d5 the
the typical
plan is king b1 and knight comes to c1
might see queen a5 oh queen e5 is
illegal
needs to play c5 first
okay let's go after the bishop
at the right moment i'd like to play
g4
c4 can be annoying yeah
um
i don't really want to play c3
i can just play e5 make things crazy
c3 queen d4 probably
it's a weird position
and now the bishop helps defend also can
help attack
okay queen d4
it's actually not easy for black to
remove the queen
question is what to do c3 is still kind
of annoying
maybe this move
it's kind of a long-term problem but the
hope is that
black can't like immediately meet me
which i'm not sure about
i think if takes i want to take with
bishop or
knight let's take with knight preventing
knight c5
a very strange position my black looks
really passive
these pawns are annoying
okay trying to get some attack on my own
[Music]
i don't care about pawns i just care
about open files
and eventually checkmates
i give takes i might even just sack and
rook h1
okay with that i think i'll probably
should take
first
and rook f1
that really just comes down to who can
attack quicker
i like my chances my pieces are well
placed
i'm looking for ideas though like maybe
stacking f7
maybe this move
queen d3 bishop f5
i'll try rook f4
that's hard to find like a way to crack
the position
whoa what does this move
that kind of works i guess
or does it work is this move
if queen takes i'm happy to trade and
win the rook oh
i forgot about that move
i'm in big trouble
i have to trade queens
okay bishop here is a threat
this is really bad though
oh am i just getting made it i'm just
losing a rock
and dirty flagging is only hope
lights are tricky nights are very tricky
i didn't deserve to win that oh i feel
so bad about that
but also kind of good i don't know
this is why they invented hand sanitizer
i have to clean away the dirtiness
okay hey i crossed 2500 again
top 150 that was a really crazy game
i feel bad that it came down to that we
need a dirty flagger
or something yeah it's another
another one to make
[Music]
center for trick i know b4
so with this line i think takes an f5
yeah this is interesting
i think it's supposed to be good for
black
the queen d4 will offer the queen trade
25 out of 27.
oh queens moved backwards
that was nice okay
that's clean that was like mostly
opening preparation too
it's a funny line in this uh center fork
trap
variation also
yeah sorry if i'm missing subs but thank
you venelli 53
and everyone else who subbed who i
didn't
call out
[Music]
anyway okay life goes on oh opponent has
a really good win streak against me
let's try and recover oh slime
um i'll play knight c3
um i'm kind of just inventing stuff
i guess i'll take an h3
maybe this move queen b3 queensland
castling
also the queen's aligned with the bishop
which is undefended if f6 maybe bishop
f4
you're probably e4
you have to retreat
and treat some more
threading this
yeah here we're just trading they file
will open
blackouts of bishop hair
pawns defended
start with f3 f5 can be strong
oh i'm still up a pawn i forgot about
that opponent gave me a pawn
on the first move
oh there's this idea not sure if that
does anything
but the pawns pinned to the mating
square
okay maybe 95
active move want to play this next
some idea of b4 b52
okay yeah that's reasonable
we'll probably see four let's reinforce
things
i'm debating what i should take back
with
leaning towards knight takes just more
active square for the knight
and i hit the bishop
and i see five ideas
wow so our game history has been very
streaky
i like the time situation
i probably just want to take
okay so black took first bishop's
attacked
b-pawn's hanging
i don't know if i care
there's 94 ideas
[Music]
hmm
i'd like to make knight c5 work
let's go for this spend too much time
there
so bishop b2 rogue 294
king f2 and the bishops whoa what is
this move
wow
fancy
very fancy
that was a good decision
okay let's save the rook
losing pawns
man this is not easy
oh i'm getting forked too
oh no
yeah black played really well there
oh some hope rookie 8
and i have so many pawns too
and so many bishops
[Music]
no stalemate that's such a funny
stalemate idea
oh it's not even stalemate though
please tell me please
it wasn't stalemate right yeah the king
had
had b4 but it almost looks like
stalemates
i think that's why black didn't take the
rook
gg some 2500 on the dot
um half hour left okay
i'll try and finish somewhat strong
hey it's lexiconius welcome back
[Music]
wait lexiconius you sent me you sent me
tea right
because i picked up a package today
which i think is i think there's tea in
here i'm not sure
it's some kind of fan mail
anyway maybe i'll open the package after
the tournament
and see what's inside
oh c5 is interesting i think i'll take
and queen queen d2 i wasn't supposed to
be here until monday
today saturday
then maybe someone else sent me
something i don't know
all right let's um
[Music]
i think i'll treat this like a dragon
and just go
yugoslav style the castle queen side
b5 is very aggressive
doesn't do anything
objectively it's probably best to take
that but
i'd rather just check made on the king
side
um it's getting a little bit crazy
but i think crazy like the good kind of
crazy oh
what is this no this is a crazy kind of
crazy
what is this
so if i take i lose i can't take that
but i could play queen e3
what is this 23.85
now the a3 let's try this
that makes sense i have this move
knight moves i win the bishop so maybe
f5
what is this
i might just be losing the pawn
whoa what is this b3
opponents playing like alien moves
i can take that i think
and queen your intake also this move
oh you have to be careful let's start
with this move
i'll probably just take the pawn i'll be
able to piece i'm down a lot of time
yeah there's annoying initiative
i think i'll just take great match with
levy yesterday
oh thank you it was a fun
okay i'm going to go for 92
just trying to consolidate
so objectively white's much better here
the time situation is not easy
wow that's a good move mean what do i
even do
it might not even be better anymore
i'm gonna sack and try and made on g7 or
bishop f4
g5 is a threat
oh good move maybe this move
there's my king
here's my rook
that was a weird game opponent confused
me
and i got too long time i allowed e5
this is not a good move to allow
so in hindsight i should i should have
moved quicker
but also should have put my bishop
bishop would have loved to be on e5
attacking and defending anyway
yeah i've only played well um definitely
yeah don't don't accuse
the the player of engine use that is
definitely not an engine
it was very uh i mean there's weird
moves but
um there's some players with the style
of like just
very creative aggression
it's it's kind of opposite of engine
play
um okay life goes on
27 27 minutes left
have a qgd i've had a pretty good score
overall in this tournament
on my rating i'll play that h5
i don't really know much theory here i
just know that
eventually
either takes or b5 maybe b5
eventually black does this stuff and
white has some space advantage in the
center
and then it's just kind of a fight
i have to be careful allowing a4
it's okay so now i'm i'm preparing to
take over the a file
yeah just want to play queen eight
i think this could very easily fizzle
out to
just a drawing endgame
yeah we're just trading everything
white's probably slightly better
i'll start with f6 pondering
the possibility of e5 even right now
the problem is the knight's coming to d3
so probably have to prepare it
oh wants to play knight a5
it might probably take
sort of this
okay so now can i play e5
i think it's okay i think king's gonna
wind up on d7 in the end
assuming we trade everything
this pawn's weak but this is actually a
past pawn
so if we trade knight for bishop
ending is definitely not lost for me
play g6 first
and this this is kind of a long-term
weakness like i might go for bishop b2
bishop a3
at the right moment
let's improve the king first
the whole idea of h5 is to get the
square
oh white wants to play knight h4
not sure what's going on here
this could just be a draw or the game
yeah game continues
i don't know who's playing for a win but
probably white because i'm about to flag
i'm also about to maybe win a pawn okay
this is just a draw
yeah light's going for the dirty flag
oh that was just winning for me
that's what you get for for doing that
okay i've probably done that before too
where like you try and dirty flag and
then you just lose
that was nice
so white played g6 very much the wrong
moment
which was weird because like i was
already pre-moving i was pre-moving back
and forth
so definitely not the right timing
okay it feels good
definitely on the worst side of that
that uh end game to say final bit splits
in my last oh the final final bits
final bits remember to upload this
a nice game by the way yeah it's been a
fun tournament
thanks so much cole
all right let's play d4 he's the only
one who can dirty flag
[Music]
hmm
oh thank you marvin x for subbing
i feel like karma's gonna
happen at some point and given all the
dirty flags i've
achieved this tournament
wait what the bishop was on that f8
oh i was supposed to play knight beef no
yeah i supposed to play knight b5
okay well this is not a good line
or maybe maybe it's not so bad
because i do have a director bishop
probably losing the pawn
this is interesting i can live with this
so queen e7 i have this move
and target the d6 square
oh this is actually really nice so i'm
threatening this i'm also threatening to
take
and fork so rookie 8 looks like a
an attempt oh that's probably a better
attempt
so if i play queen e4 there's f5
unfortunately
oh but i have this move turning main and
threading this
this is working out very nicely
should consider queen h3 or queen h4
even
oh let's just win material
and then i have this move and then c4
it's actually hard to get out of the pin
there's my
but then still c4
d5 coming
what is this opponent wants to win my
queen
so bishop d3
knight's a little bit stuck
what is this
so i'm throwing probably this
yeah i'll just simplify
okay time is fine
knight c6 maybe
maybe i won't play d5 just keep the
pawns
controlling squares
hmm
so this i i fork meanwhile i want a rook
lift
oh it's a fork
i was not expecting black to take on e2
okay i think the rook still wants to be
here
black going for this then h3
a7 is hanging
bishop's attacked
what oh interesting
okay some other rook
it should be pretty routine conversion
but you never know
the queen g4 coming
um
eric the first don't know what to say oh
wait i don't know i got it hello eric
actually that stuff
wait what sure do i know hello eric
rosen
oh hello how's it going
oh hey neil how's it going thanks for
subbing
for eight months welcome back
thanks for the the greeting
okay 15 minutes
i'm gonna play uh do i do this
no let's be normal let's be normal for a
little bit
play d5
castle okay
so we have a very typical
[Music]
scotch end game where black has two
bishops
white has slightly annoying
positional play
by positional play two
okay making alpha zero proud initial c3
not sure what my plan is
the plan is to do something let's take
yeah black's definitely slightly better
here with this pawn
nice bishop the rook can't access e1
i'll theme color the bishop in white's
territory
there's rook g3 we can repeat
wait oh white's bishop is kind of
hanging too
okay i'll defend
i think it works no it doesn't work
let's do this
oh my ah i thought i was so clever
double attacking
ah
that's me oh that's me oh wow what a
mate i was like what
at first i thought it was stalemate
let's check me wow
oh that was very clever oh no
i just wondered a rook i was so excited
to attack two undefended pawns
ah that's what happens after three hours
of blitz
okay i'm going to try and finish above
2500
stafford gamba time let's do this
maybe maybe not
we'll wait okay vienna time
queen e2 i assume the same idea applies
i'm just playing kind of based on feel
queenie choose a new move for me
but my plan is after this to play knight
d4
maybe that doesn't quite work is queen
actually no queen e3 i've knight c2
right takes knight d4 queen d3
i can take
oh my bishop hangs in the end
i wanted to make knight d4 work
94
it probably just doesn't work
[Music]
maybe i'll take i'm going to take first
and i'll still have 94 ideas
now basically i'm going to be down upon
but white's going to be underdeveloped
there will be pressure against c2
maybe queen h4 ideas
but this is this is unknown territory
hmm play this move
this might just win back upon live d4 d4
doesn't
ah this should be five good move
okay this is just bad for me
f6
yeah just an opening going wrong
so i'm down upon i have terribly weak
king
the only good thing is that white's
still kind of underdeveloped
and there's pressure
expecting white i was expecting castling
because here i can play take on d4
there's e6 in that line
e6 is crazy okay let's take here
really not feeling comfortable
like everything's going wrong
i'll try this
i'm going to have to select exchange
unless
um everything's going wrong here
time-wise too
i'm fighting i am trying to fight
unlocking f3
no
ah
how i survive like this middle game
position
i just didn't have enough time left
it was almost like a miracle come back
and even this ended
in the near future also there is
feedback on the mic is
oh is it a mic pad sorry the the fridge
is making noises
i'll probably i'll probably like just
invest in like a much better microphone
or just a fridge that doesn't make
noises
i'm moving the light closer so
hopefully it's better okay back to
tournaments
probably we'll be playing the last game
no change i'm sorry i know yeah i know
there's a little bit of like background
noise
um
i'll do some research if anyone has like
good
microphone suggestions i mean there's
this thing
i have this thing but this actually has
more background noise
i think it's like a little bit broken
okay let's play
a final final game berserking budapest
gambit
first budapest of today uh we'll have a
fun
line maybe let's
take in knight c6
so there's a line queen d5 queen a3
rook c1 f6 also this line
so i'll win back the pawn queen helps
attack
now i just want to play positionally
also thanks for subbing haywood jabloom
welcome back
subbing for half a year
okay it's going to be very positional
oh i blundered upon
it's actually not that bad because i'll
probably win c4
unless white wins another pawn but then
i could maybe win a pawn
okay c1 expected
just try and attack
oh white wants the queen
i have a crazy idea like really crazy
let's do it there's a d5
i guess there's queen queen b5 queen f1
i'm just going all out
so sac exchange but i'm going to have
all my things
and a is always guarded which is nice if
f3 i'll win the pawn
actually there's a line f3 takes here
and then i can't quite sack
yeah the rooks are not really useful in
helping defend
let's preserve book d4 is coming
have to allow it
[Music]
interesting
as pawn is very very strong
there goes my c pawn
and i don't even know what the goal is
at this point maybe it's trade queens
and survive
why probably has to trade queens
otherwise i win the pawn okay that was
very generous
i'm feeling hope
[Music]
f4 i take or just take
oh scary
that's a fitting end
ah that's a very fitting end
i was very fitting into the treatment